BOUM YouTube,
je sais, on dirait que ça fait Daamn les gens [Imite Tibo Inshape]
mais on s'en fou car je suis très content
Je suis extrêmement content de vous annoncer officiellement, enfin la date de mon 1er Meet Up
J'avais annoncé il y a quelques mois qu'à 50 000 abonnés on ferait un Meet Up
On a passé les 50 000 et très rapidement les 100 000
donc ça devient le Meet up des 50 000 - 100 000 on sait plus trop
Depuis plusieurs semaines je cherchais le lieu où on allait le faire dans Paris,
donc je comptais privatiser un endroit,
Le Lieu et après sur place vous auriez payé vos boissons, vos repas ce genre de chose.
Et bien j'ai une bien meilleure nouvelle que ça
puisque le YouTube Space Paris m'a proposé d'organiser le Meet Up chez eux
dans leur locaux qui sont eux même
dans les locaux de Google France
Si vous suivez bien la chaîne vous avez déjà compris que ça serait le 12 octobre
donc ce sera bien le 12 octobre prochain de 18h à 20h30
au YouTube Space Paris qui se trouve 8 rue de Londres
entre Trinité et Gare Saint Lazare
donc il va se passer plusieurs choses, il y aura un espace de Talk avec Donatien au départ, une sorte Foire aux questions en live
|Imite des personnes] "oui mais FAQ ça veut pas dire Foire aux questions"
Oui mais on peut quand même dire Foire aux questions si on en a envie
Je pense bien en profiter pour vous mentaliser un petit peu
et filmer tout ça aussi pour la chaîne pour ceux qui pourront pas venir,
soit parce qu'ils sont pas à Paris, soit parce qu'ils sont pas disponibles.
On oubliera pas tout le reste de la Team Mentalo, quand même.
et après on aura 1h30 2h pour se rencontrer, pour discuter, boire des coups ensemble
puisque c'est YouTube qui nous offre toutes les consommations,
il prévoit tout sur place
et en ça, c'est super cool. Merci à eux
Merci pour moi, mais surtout Merci pour vous en fait.
Parce que perso, j'aurai pas pu vous inviter pour tous ce qui était conso
Voilà, je suis ravi de ça
et... vous voulez peut être la procédure *rire* pour pouvoir venir
Je vous mets un lien dans la description
Vous cliquez sur ce lien, c'est un formulaire de chez YouTube
Vous vous inscrivez dessus
Ça fonctionne sur la règle du 1er arrivé, 1er servi
Vous vous inscrivez, vous avez un petit mail de confirmation comme quoi vous êtes pré-inscrit à l'évènement
Et dans quelques jours, YouTube vous confirmera que tout est OK
Parce que on va vérifié 1 par 1 que les personnes puissent bien venir
Histoire qu'il y ai une place vacante alors que quelqu'un aurait pu venir
1er arrivé, 1er servi ça veut dire aussi que ça part vite
puisqu'il y a qu'une centaine de place
Mais en même temps tout le monde n'est pas disponible le 12 octobre
Tout le monde ne va pas voir cette vidéo dés samedi matin à 11h
Tout le monde n'habite pas Paris ou n'a pas forcément la possibilité d'être à Paris le 12 octobre
donc si vous pouvez venir, si vous voulez venir, n'hésitez pas
Je sais pas si ça se voit mais je suis très excité et très heureux que ça se passe enfin
et qu'on se rencontre réellement
Il y aura d'autres Meet Up, ailleurs en France au fur et à mesure des mois qui viennent
Mais le meilleur moyen de se rencontrer et on l'a vu juste là le 23 septembre à la Garenne Colombe
C'était super cool
C'est si vous venez à un spectacle, de m'attendre à la fin
Donc pour voir toute les dates de spectacle vous allez sur le site
www.fabienolicard.fr
il y a toutes les dates de tournée
(Je vous mets le lien dans la description également)
Sur le site vous trouverez plein de choses dont toutes les dates de tournée qui sont officialisées
Et de temps en temps on en rajoute comme ça assez régulièrement dés qu'on signe dans un autre théâtre
et que je suis sûr de venir dans une autre ville je vous le mets
Ça va être cool ça va être mortel on va enfin se rencontrer par autre chose qu'un écran interposé
Si vous aussi vous êtes content qu'on se voit le 12 octobre
ou qu'on se voit sur une date de tournée
Vous pouvez mettre un petit pouce en l'air
Si vous êtes fraîchement arrivés sur la chaîne, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir
Et n'oubliez pas le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre, on doit être à la 275 aujourd'hui
Donc rendez vous demain à 11h
Tchao !